[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants j'espère que vous
êtes allé sagement vous couchez hier
soir ainsi que je vous l'avez demandé
oui ils ont dit oui patron tant mieux je
suis ravi que grosso reçoit presque
guérie
car ils étaient bien grincheux ces jours
ci me patron ça fait mal aux oreilles
rond laisse pas les enfants vous voyez
ils ont dit oui patron et hop je t'ai
sans voir mes habits mirabel et p'tits
loups il fait attention aux courants
d'air gros rui pop hip hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
bonjour jose fêtent noël la chasse aux
papillons mais on n'a pas de papillon va
trouver un toit
fais toi eux pas dit non c'est pas bien
c'est un p'tit louis tu as triché à moi
même un droit c'est toi le papillon
bonbons c'est moi le papillon à il
laisse la tête me faire moi comme ça
c'est un beau papillon je lis gros pas
pu aller voir toi papillon utah cap
[Musique]
papillon regardez la jolie flèche qu'est
ce qui t'arrive papillonner tu t'es
connaît contre un arbre bizarre bizarre
non plus de fleurs jeu dangereux le
fleuve j'allais papillon rien
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est du bien le binôme hier un petit
papillon je butine ceo du miel
d'abeilles les copains et les coquins
ils m'ont eu que je me suis laissé
prendre
minute papillon on compare d'en haut
minutes patron j'arrive selon les
enfants on lit on vitesse à demain on va
s'coucher tous elle n'ose comme légaux
avant papillon à demain à demain les
enfants
[Musique]
et oui les enfants
les gourmands sont toujours punis
ah voilà notre papillon qui revient mon
pauvre gros ours ils t'ont encore
rattraper décidément tu ne changeras
jamais aux seuls acteurs dior fois que
je fais le papillon pas trop j'ai juré
bonne et les petits enfants allaient
sagement vous coucher comme petit lou ye
mirabel à demain allons en automne ours
en route patron à demain
[Musique]
vous